[Music]
ah yes the pivotal question that you
guys want answered
can you play pubg on the ipad 8. can you
do a video review playing pubg on the
ipad 8. can you test pubg on the ipad 8
well sure we can
here at the geek labs we are going to
test out pubg call of duty mobile and
mobile legends bang bang to see if the
ipad 8 is worth your monies at all
so
let's hop to it we have pubg setup on
the ipad 8 we're going to just go
through the settings to see what we've
got here so
right
we're going to graphics
and of course
we want our
ultra
hd
so we'll wait for that to download the
pack and then of course we want the
frame rate to be ultra we're gonna
enable anti-aliasing as well
and everything else should be all right
right so we got everything in check so
we're going to
play
some pub g
so what we've got is uh the ultra hd
pack so the graphics setting is way high
everything looks good
we don't
i don't see any frame rate drops
currently but we'll see once we start
the game
[Music]
piece of [ __ ]
oh you punch me i'm afraid
[Music]
wow nobody
oh [ __ ] okay somebody
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
oh okay we won
so there you have it folks
it runs perfectly fine on the ipad 8.
okay so
with this being said let's try and win
another game on call of duty mobile
alright so we got call of duty mobile
set setup on the ipad 8 let's go check
our settings real quick as well
we'll go for advanced mode because we
are pros
okay
and
we are going to also check
the audio and graphics settings
the graphic quality was set to very high
frame rate let's hit to max which is
max
i'm going to enable
ragdolls depot field
and
anything else
we'll be honored to adjust
[Music]
oh well done
enemies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]
okay so we're playing mobile legends
bang bang i'm gonna pick bruno here
and start the game
this is on ultra settings
i'm gonna press high framerate mulch
so playing at 60.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yep that's another win so three wins
three for three
[Music]
well done
all right
so the final verdict can he play games
yes can he play games in high graphic
settings yes
can it play in high frame rate modes
definitely yes so for a 499 singapore
dollars price tag
you do get something that's faster than
a snapdragon 855 phone and if you're a
casual mobile gamer this is probably
something perfect for you the ip8 could
possibly be the best value to
performance tablet that we've seen on
the market however those who are more to
the competitive gamer side might want to
give this a miss as the ipa doesn't have
the high frame rate like 120 hertz
screen that we see on the ipad pro and
the samsung galaxy s7 tab plus because
as you all know more frames wins
but all in all the ipad 8 is still
perfect for everyday use and not only
just for gaming
so that's it
you've got your verdict you guys wanted
a review we've done it and if you have
not seen our exclusive hands-on video on
the ipad 8 do check it out link in the
description below if you enjoyed this
video do give us a thumbs up and share
this with your good old bunch of friends
and if you haven't already do consider
subscribing and smash that notification
bell icon so you can stay updated to our
latest geeky news and tidbits
until then this is zaki signing off
[Music]
you